I was in the room with a very
conservative CMO and she was really
drilling me she was like but what's the
ROI of social media and I'm giving her
my best stuff for example if you want
some best stuff go look at what your
engagement rate is on your Facebook page
you have a certain amount of fans and
then you have a post they look at the
number as a point oh one is a point oh
two it doesn't matter how many fans and
Twitter followers you have it's how many
of them are gonna buy something and give
a [ __ ]
so she's drilling mean I'm giving her
some really good metrics at least for a
2011 world and she's pushing and I know
why she works in a conservative company
and the more conservative she comes
across the more likely she'll be the CEO
I get it I'm fine but she's pushing and
pushing and finally I look at her and I
go she's like Bagheri
what's the ROI and I'm like today she's
like but what's the real ROI of social
media and I'm doing my normal thing like
can you give me the ROI of television
and print because I love that you spend
a shitload of money on Vogue and you're
buying the subscription but can you
guarantee me that somebody's looking at
the ad on page 139 cuz you can't and I'm
giving her everything I've got and she's
still punching me directly in the throat
so I had to pull it out she goes what's
the ROI of social media what's the ROI
of social media so I look at her and go
what's the ROI of your mother
she said excuse me I said uh
I said I have no interest in making a
mother joke and I'm not making fun of
you but let me explain one thing to you
the ROI of my mother is everything the
reason I'm going to buy a multi-billion
dollar sports franchise is because of my
mother my mother
the way she parented me which oh by the
way is perfectly is the reason I have
the ability the confidence and absolute
wherewithal to execute the businesses
that I'm building however my friends at
Inc 500 I cannot come to you with slides
and put him on those screens and say
over here click in sixth grade when I
got a mullet you know and my mom said I
was gorgeous and beautiful and I could
do anything
well that was building self-esteem and
so what I did with that it on the next
slide is you'll see here I sold a couple
more cases of wine in 1994 because of
that self-esteem which led to this and
now I can't show you I can't show you in
data the ROI of my mother but I promise
you it's all of it
the whole kit and caboodle socials going
to prove it because social has way
better metrics than traditional some
[ __ ] stood at the top of a building
with a clicker and counted how many cars
drove by a billboard and that's the
metrics we're using do you know that
people do little [ __ ] scantron like
cards to tell Nielsen's what shows they
watched are you [ __ ] kidding me
however thank you for that one clap that
meant a lot however however we keep
poking holes in social you know why I
know the size of your company similar to
Romney used to you're busy
you're doing a lot of stuff and you need
to grow I get it but please audit
yourself figure out what you're doing
when people always talk to me and say
but how do you scale this I say you take
all the money you're spending on dumb
[ __ ] and you put it into humans